what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today I'm going to be talking
about the latest crazy developments in
the demon Slayers story if you enjoyed
these weekly Demon Slayer chapter
reviews smash that like button and share
this video with a friend if you haven't
be sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification about or you will
miss future Demon Slayer videos remember
that you can check out these reviews
before they come out on YouTube by
following anime up or audio on Spotify
iTunes or wherever you listen to podcast
thank you to our glorious patrons who
helped us survive YouTube issues and who
helped make videos like this one
possible more on these amazing people at
the end of the video for now keep in
mind there will be manga spoilers I'm
going to be talking about the latest
chapter chapter 194 after all without
further ado let's jump into it we start
the chapter with Murata and ushido and
the chapter is called burning wounds
remember that last time ton zero again
seemed to have the upper hand against
moves on and it was mainly because as we
found out Tom Mayo was Chernobyl's help
made an aging poison that has been
slowing down moves on his body needs to
redirect more and more energy for
fighting the aging process and that's
causing him to slow down and weaken this
explains why he was at one point
struggling with the other demon slayers
and why tundra is still not dead even
though he's not at the same level that
you're Ichi the strongest Demon Slayer
in history was we take a quick detour
away from the main fight though as you
shiro sees Tom arrows cat this was a
crazy moment I thought that the cat died
it looked like Mouzon killed him before
however luckily it seems like the cat is
alright you should have demonized him
before the battle so that the cat can
recover from even the deadly wound that
moves on gave him this presents an
interesting idea forests ad of
demonizing living things in order to
fight Mouzon we don't let they'll be
used further but imagine Guillaume a or
Tundra or getting demonized and getting
power upgrades while continuing to
retain their humanity like you should oh
and Tom Ione did they could in theory
revive people who are on the brink of
death and make them stronger than ever
obviously this might not happen but the
fact that they successfully did it with
the cat suggests that it is an
interesting possibility nonetheless the
Demon Slayer corps members go on to
check on the wound
first in noski is shown he doesn't seem
to be doing well at all but if we
remember from the past he has insane
recovering abilities so it's possible
that he'll recover soon after being
given the serum it seems that the trio
in disguise any two and Cannell are the
only ones who haven't got the serum yet
and they need to because the serum is
what allows them to recover from moves
on cell destroying poison we see yo me
looking like a giant next to you shadow
as I guess it doesn't seem like he'll be
in any position to fight his leg is done
for and the bleeding and lack of balance
will according to you she to make it
impossible for him to fight now imagine
if you should have demonized him
successfully he could make a full
recovery like the cat this is definitely
something to keep in mind as we move
forward if it would help kill Mouzon i'm
sure many pillars would be willing to do
something like that we see that there
are only 50 minutes left so 9 minutes
have passed since last chapter that
normally wouldn't seem like a lot but
since some chapters happen within the
span of one minute that is a significant
jump we are getting closer to dawn
perhaps slowly but surely as you should
restrain the wounded he's sweating and
crying making clear that demons can be
the same as humans they too can cry in
fact I don't consider you know to be any
less human than the others he just so
happens to have demon enhancements but
he hasn't lost his humanity at all to
himself he begs Tamayo to somehow
protect congedo and as we know from the
last chapter even from beyond the grave
she has been helping to protect him she
poisoned moves on and he's aging quick
last chapter he already aged over 9000
years her cells are in Mouzon and we saw
her still being defiant to moves on when
he asked her about being poisoned your
ichi spared her in the past and the
other demon Slayers of the time held it
against him however it was one of the
best decisions you'd eat she made since
then tama yo has done more to help stop
Moloch than any of those
holier-than-thou demon Slayers who
wanted your Ichi to commit seppuku it is
very possible that we still haven't seen
the last of her she might have even more
tricks up her sleeves that we haven't
seen yet for now we jump back to the
main battle and pendulum moves on are
still going at it
props the moves on he's been waving his
tentacles around non-stop for countless
thirst and for him it must feel like
thousands of years however he's still
going tonzura thinks that if he connects
a technique it's endless
he must aim for Muslims hearts and
brains precisely he's trying to focus
and enter the see-through world but it
is not working he's lacking oxygen so
it's not even like Mouzon is failing to
kill a selfless state tun judo who has
access to the see-through world he's
actually so weakened at this point that
he is failing to kill eaten judo who has
yet to access these states I'm guessing
that the wound on his face must have
something to do with his lack of oxygen
in his breathing trouble his father and
you Ichi proved that it was possible but
Tundra is really having trouble
nonetheless and it might be because of
that wound yes he got treatment but he's
clearly not back to normal yet it's
possible that just as Mulan is getting
slowed down by the aging poison so as
Tundra getting slowed down by that
infection he's trying to calm down smell
moves on and reassure himself that he
can do it but then he messes up in such
a battle it can all be over after one
mess-up and it might have been over if
not for the MVP of this chapter II guru
you go to save stand row for the second
time in this fight what a fricking boss
eager dose intervention let's tundra
catch his breath and his vision starts
to come back remember that ego doe wants
to die the feeding moves on so he's been
prepared to fight right to the end from
the beginning
despite this attitude you can't help but
feel shocked when you see that both of
his eyes have been cut and he can no
longer see he was in many ways known for
his eyes which were unique because they
were different colors his eyes made him
special in the eyes of the snake demon
that wanted to eat him when he was still
a kid and then there's the question of
what meet suti will think when she sees
these horrible injuries it seems like
Iguodala will never be able to see the
love of his life again even if he
survives which really sucks still though
he doesn't complain or whine he keeps
fighting he even tells Tundra not to
worry about others like a true man eager
to shrugs the loss of his eyes off
saying that his right eye was already
weak in the first place so it's no
biggie even though he can no longer see
he says he doesn't need tons of help
since he has Kabu tomorrow his pet snake
he drops Tundra
he's recovered and bravely continues to
fight moves on it's amazing that he can
fight without sight by communicating
with his pet snake who is letting him
know the situation the snake appears to
be able to read Milan's attacks yo mate
could also fight without mission but the
snake whisperer aspect is very
interesting pets have definitely played
an important role in this story from
tomorrow's cat too eager a snake not
only humans but other creatures of the
natural world are helping out in order
to defeat moves on the team effort goes
beyond one species and I appreciate that
we see tons attack take the form of a
fire dragon like we did before
while eager to compliments his attacks
with his snake form attacks I said
during the last chapter when we saw
tangelos dragon move that I'd love to
see him use it in combination with
designing tools lightning dragon
attacked and it seems like we might be
close since the same idea happened with
a guru and xeni too might wake up
anytime too there are few things that
would be more epic than a ton judo's any
two dragon tag team moves on is
frustrated as usual because he can't
kill Iguodala or tons it off even though
they're so injured then moves on says
something interesting he says it's the
ageing potion he still hasn't adapted
and recovering from it is sapping his
strength
so clearly the story is setting up the
idea of Mulan adapting to the potion
down the line so I'm thinking we can
definitely expect that hopefully in that
time Natsu Cole zenny Tzu and the others
will be there to help even out the power
imbalance for now though tons of notices
that moves on sent is changing he's
still strong but it seems like
everyone's attacks have weakened him
four times oh he can still barely keep
breathing and avoid oxygen deprivation
so he can't enter the sea through aka
transparent world again this is very
strange to me and it has to be the
result of the injuries moves on gave to
him perhaps no Zuko will be able to
purge moves on cell destroying blood
from congedo completely and he'll be
able to use his full power finally that
will probably happen along with moves on
adapting to the poison so we might see a
full power moves on versus full power
tons of fight that would definitely make
for an amazing finale until then though
tundra is still struggling two on one
against moves on he comments on how my
boy agura has saved him many times and
how he needs to help him
that's when one of the biggest twists
happens moves ons body starts changing
and all of a sudden you start seeing all
these old scars appearing on his body
then we figure out that your each she
didn't just mentally scar moves on he
physically scarred him too in our
patrons s chord we discussed how insane
your ichi is again after this chapter I
keep thinking they can't up his epicness
anymore and then the mangaka finds away
hundreds of freaking years past people
and moves on has not recovered from
those wounds your Ichi burnt moves on at
a cellular level not only that those
scars reveal bosons weak spots as Tantra
says even now you're a teacher showing
them the way man no one there moves on
is so traumatized after your deep Chi
that dude has to be considered a bigger
monster strength wise then moves on will
ever be and I love how they combine that
traumatizing monstrous level of strength
with one of the most humble
personalities in anime as I mentioned
before Tundras yo Deecee successor
yuuichi felt like his purpose in life
was to kill Mouzon and he thought he was
worthless because he couldn't finish him
off in his lifetime
however he set the stage for moves on to
be defeated by saving Tama yo and
passing down his breath style and now
showing everyone where Milan's weak
spots are it's over simplifying the
matter to say that you're a teach he did
it all alone but he fulfilled his
purpose he did what he could to ensure
that future generations will have the
best possible chance to beat mousse on
the legend died standing up and the
injuries that he inflicted left scars
for centuries after his death even on
the strongest demon with the strongest
regenerative power we're talking both
physical and psychological scars amazing
obviously we all want tundra to win in
the end but I'm glad that we're getting
such an interesting back-and-forth
battle I'm glad that moves on has depth
to his character
he's not just some overconfident villain
who has never tasted the feat in a very
human way he's been traumatized by a guy
way stronger than him and he's still
carrying that with him he's morally
terrible and he treats humans as if they
were insects but he's also very human in
his fear and trauma the mangaka is
making it clear that he hasn't quite
left behind his humaneness even though
he's the strongest demon now all that's
missing is for us to get more of his
backstory showing how he loved
cared about someone once I really
wouldn't be surprised if we got
something like that before moves ons
defeat but whatever happens moves on
really shows like Coco she beau did how
the fear of dying can turn one into a
monstrous creature how trying to fight
the rules of nature and the natural
course of nature can make you monstrous
obviously most people don't like the
idea of dying but the quote-unquote good
guys aka honourable and praiseworthy
characters in the series willingly
accept that when it's their time to go
good eat she embraced it
George Udo embraced it and we cheater
embraced it even though they all could
have potentially turned into demons and
escaped from death's grasp however to
them their honor and principles
prevented them from doing such a
cowardly thing they died but they died
honorably and in doing so inspired the
ones that came after to finish the job
they started I mentioned that other
natural creatures were coming together
along with humans in order to stop moves
on I don't think this is a coincidence
it almost seems like the universe is
trying to assert its laws which moves on
broke by trying to live forever it seems
clear that moves on is doomed to failure
and in another kind of story
Mulan might have been the tragic
protagonist of the story who tries
pointlessly to escape faith and the laws
of nature in saying that I'm not trying
to imply that Mulan
doesn't deserve whatever is coming to
him he definitely does my point is just
that the mangaka has done a good job of
constructing a three-dimensional villain
who's very human flaws turned him into a
monster more than anything else as a
human we can take either path we can act
with virtue and bravely accept what
happens or we can let our cowardice turn
us into monstrous creatures that will
commit any evil in order to preserve
ourselves for as long as possible moves
on is an interesting villain not because
he's so demonic but because he's so
human but anyways that's it for today's
video thank you all so much for watching
let me know what you're expecting for
the next chapter it almost seems like
every chapter ends up with Tundra
somehow having an upper hand and then
the next chapter quickly reverses that
and then we keep going back and forth
but I don't mind that since it's keeping
things interesting and the mangaka
definitely has a lot more cards to play
including the Zuko and xeni - if you
enjoy these weekly chapter reviews and
want to keep them
humming make sure to smash that like
button to let me know if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or else you
will miss future Demon Slayer videos
remember that you can listen to these
reviews before they're uploaded on
youtube if you follow anime up or audio
on Spotify iTunes or wherever you listen
to podcasts a special thank you goes out
to our patrons over on patreon who help
us survive YouTube issues and who helped
make videos like this one possible first
and foremost I want to thank our don't
want ear patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans Stephen and Radha aloha
attempt the world Steelers the School
Bus Tyson Kirino and a quiet respect and
I can't forget our pro hero to your
patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings out
just fit edala beat Anatole kazansky
alpha deal
angel Cruz team Sparky 65 cricket XP
Rohan Kapoor Jessica Maloney Emperor
otaku Timothy Edward Vargas Jeanne d'Arc
Joel Stanton jccc Wacha and John Bunton
thank you all so much and man that list
is growing if you enjoy our work you can
support more by going over to patreon
comm anime uproar and becoming a patron
today for as little as $1 if you do so
you'll gain a feature in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access for a
private patient only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course dank
memes so check out patreon.com/lenguin
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see you
space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]